Alright Michael. I'm going to define a new concept
for you. It is called the NASH EQUILIBRIUM.
>> Nice.
>> Okay, here's the set up. You have n players. So we move beyond simply
two players. You have n players. And
each player has strategies that it can chose
from. So here I'm referring to them as, S1, these are all the strategies for
player one. As two are all the strategies for player two up to S N
all the players for strategy N. Got it?
>> Yep. Okay so each of these are set, so im
going to say that the particular strategies, S1 star S2 star
S3 star, so on and so forth as N star that
is a strategy that each of the N players has chosen.
>> Is in a Nash equilibrium if and only if for each one of those strategies
chosen by the n players it is the strategy
that maximizes the utility for that particular player, it
is the strategy that maximize the utility for that
particular player Given all the other strategies that were
chosen. Now I actually find that difficult to kind
of work through, so let me try to say
it a different way. Given that you have a
set of strategies as one star, as two star,
as three star, as n star. We know that they
are in Nash equilibrium, if and only if. If you randomly
chose one of the players, and gave them the chance to
switch their strategy, they would have no reason to do it.
>> Interesting, okay.
>> So does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So an equilibrium right, just in general, the word, the word sort
of makes sense, right, an equilibrium is
at a place where everything is balanced.
And in some sense, there's no reason
for anything to move because they're in balance.
So we set that a set of strategies are a Nash Equilibrium if no one person
has any reason to change their strategy
in a world where everyone else's strategy remains
the same. Then you're, then you're in equilibrium,
and in particular you're in a Nash equilibrium.
>> Nash equilibrium. Okay good.
>> Do you know who Nash is?
>> Ogden Nash was a poet.
>> Not that Nash.
>> I think there was a TV series with a Nash in it.
>> Yes there was.
>> But you're thinking of John Nash.
>> That's right The Nobel Prize winning person who
was the, was featured in the movie A Beautiful Mind.
>> Yep, that's exactly right. And it
was, in fact, a Beautiful Equilibrium. Okay,
so, there's the notion of a Nash Equilibrium. It was admitted by John Nash,
if you believe the movie, in order to pick up women. Which
I, you know, you know I never, I've never seen this movie.
>> Oh really? Oh, I watched it and it was, it was
surprising how unhelpful it was in explaining what a Nash Equilibrium was.
>> [LAUGH] I'm not surprised. I hope this is helpful, though. So,
it really is a kind of difficult concept to completely wrap your, your
mind around, but what it really boils down to is, listen, if
we all picked a bunch of strategies and we knew that one other
person, one of us, we don't know who before hand, but we know
that one of us Would have the opportunity to change their strategy after they
see what everyone else's strategy is. We'd be in a nash equilibrium only
if that person, whoever that person is, has no reason to change their strategy.
>> Gotcha. So, so specifically you've made a distinction
between strategies that were pure and strategies that were mixed.
>> Right.
>> And I guess I don't see in this case which kind we're talking about.
>> Right. So,
in this particular case, we're talking about. Pure
strategies; however, exactly this wording works with mixed strategies.
>> Oh, I see. So you could have
a pure Nash equilibrium or a mixed Nash equilibrium.
>> Right. And so, you could, each one of these, instead
of choosing a particular strategy and saying they're a Nash equilibrium, you
could talk about a probability dristribution over each of these sets of
strategies and say those are Nash equilibrium if. No one would want
to change their probability distribution.
>> Got it.
>> So this works for both pure and
mixed. Alright, so you think you understand this?
>> [LAUGH] sure.
>> Good, we will test that.